Podcast UFO, it's in the brain. zurückzuerinnern, wann die letzte Hotelfolge war und ich meine, es war damals mal bei Starlight Express im Theater, wo du einen Auftritt hattest mit dem Rundfunktanzorchester. Kann das sein? Und danach waren wir in deinem Hotelzimmer. Es kann sein, dass das aus dem Tourbus sogar direkt raus war. Es ist immer eine komische Atmosphäre. Ich bin hier eigentlich in deiner Privatsphäre zu Hause, du hast extra das Bett gemacht für mich. Ich habe das Bett versucht zu machen, wie man das immer vorfindet. Und da fängt es jetzt schon an. Erstmal herzlich willkommen, Florentin Wild zu einer neuen Folge. Hallo, guten Tag, Stefan Tietze, uns in die Folge geleitet hat Ranson. Dr. Ranson? Nein. Okay, ich dachte, I'm taking a shot. No, Ranson einfach nur. Übrigens auch sehr gut. Hörst du, dass gerade vor unserer Tür gesaugt wird? Ja, da wird gesaugt, da wird geputzt, da wird gehämmert, der Aufzug ist ausgefallen aktuell, wir sind in Essen, es ist ein Riesendrama. Wir hängen jetzt hier fest im Hochhaus. Es ist richtig schlimm, ich habe gestern das Szenen an der Rezeption erlebt, das war wirklich nicht schön, wo es hieß, sie haben ein Zimmer im fünften Stock, der Aufzug fährt aber nur bis zum vierten. Und dann schaute dieser etwas betagte alte Herr auf seinen riesigen Plastik- quasi,- Plastik-Panzer. So ein bisschen wie bei der Mini-Playback-Show, wo du diese riesige Kugel hast, wo alle Kleider drin sind. Genau diese Kugel hatte der auch. Sie versteht jeder von den Züreren. Dann hast du die Ema von der Maik-Klauchis, die gesagt hat, die hat den Kugel manchmal, ist, der hat auf und aus. Und dann weißt du auch noch,
ach genau, was habe ich da eigentlich angesehen.
Vielleicht war ich auch zu klein, um die Sprache zu verstehen,
ich weiß es nicht. Aber der musste dann tatsächlich
noch ein Stockwerk seinen riesigen Plastik
und hat sich echauffiert darüber?
Der war wirklich niedergeschlagen, der wirklich
oh nein,
ein Stockwerk,
oh nein, und er so, ja soll ich
ihm helfen, meinte der Rezeptionist und er so,
das muss ich alleine machen.
Aber das ging... Ein Stockwerk. Och, ne. Und er so, ja, soll ich Ihnen helfen, meinte der Rezeptionist.
Und er so, das muss ich alleine machen.
Aber das ging ja wirklich so, als würde ich den Krieg ziehen. Dass wir in Essen nicht in einer klassischen Tourismus-Hotelstadt sind.
Nein.
Weil Touristen würden anders reagieren.
Ich glaube, eher sozusagen als Arbeiter, also nach Essen kommt man, glaube ich, auf Business-Trips.
Ja, um in die Mine zu gehen, um nochmal schön den Wolkenkratzer zu bauen. Genau, man geht unter Tage oder arbeitet ganz oben in schwindelregenden Höhen. Es gibt nur Extreme in Essen. Essen ist die Stadt der Extreme. Und ich glaube, diese Attitude zeigt mir, er ist auf einem Business-Trip hier. Sonst hat dieser alte Mann gesagt, könnt ihr mir nicht dein Zimmer tiefer geben, es ist meine erhorsame Leisure-Time. Nein, nein, Leisure-Time. Ich habe das Bett versucht zu machen, wie ich es vorgefunden habe, mit diesem Bettschal und diesen tausenden Kissen. Es hat nur so halb funktioniert. Und was sie ja vor allem machen, was jetzt glaube ich nicht der Fall war, aber sonst Stefan hat gerade so fest aufs Bett gehauen, dass die kleine Gummibärenpackung vom Kissen gefallen ist. Auch da wusste ich nicht, ich habe die aus Erinnerung da drauf gelegt. Wo liegt die denn? Die liegt auf dem Kissen tatsächlich. Das ist doch immer der Gag, dass wenn jemand so eine durchzechte Nacht hat,
irgendwie bei den Simpsons oder so,
wacht er auf und hat noch so irgendwie das Schokoladenstück
an der Stirn oder so, weil er sich da einfach eingelegt hat.
Bei den Simpsons.
Ja. Vor allem, das hätte ja fast
eine coole Rockstar-Geschichte sein können,
aber bei dir kommt dann so dieser Halbsatz rein,
wie bei den Simpsons. Ja, klar.
Wenn man dann so eine durchzechte Nacht hat und dann
hat man noch so eine Haribo-Tüte am Gesicht kleben, wie bei den Simpsons. Ich sehe die Welt in gelb. Ich kenne die Welt eigentlich nur durch die Simpsons. Ich sitze zu Hause. Deswegen liebe ich dich. So doll. Deswegen liebe ich dich. Hotel, du liebst Hotels. Du liebst Hotels, du bist immer unterwegs. Schöne Hotels, grosse Hotels, man sieht dich am Frühstücksbuffet. Wir waren heute beide gemeinsam im Frühstücksbuffet, wussten nicht genau, wie wir damit umgehen sollen. Wir sind ja der transparente Podcast. Wir sind der gläserne, transparente Podcast. Und zwar sind wir in Essen für unsere Improv-Show. Und das ist ja insofern auch spannend als Rahmenprogramm, weil Improv, man will nicht den ganzen Tag abhängen. Man kann nicht den ganzen Tag abhängen, man muss danach so auf der Bühne stehen und irgendwie ja, man muss Bock haben aufeinander. Wir hatten gestern Abend eine Show und haben heute Abend noch eine Show. Das heißt, wir sind jetzt gerade in diesem Limbo, in diesem Ladebalken-Zeit eigentlich, wo nichts passiert, wo man einfach wartet, wo man natürlich schon ein bisschen Essen genießen will, dann aber merkt, da kommt nichts. Und dann einfach sagt, okay, dann schaue ich halt nochmal Dune 2 an. Ah, wirklich? Ich habe letztens in Stuttgart Dune 2 gesehen, auf einem kleinen Bildschirm mit einer schlechten Internetverbindung. Traumhaft.
Ja, traumhaft. Genau, das ist ja so, man sagt, manche Bilder funktionieren als Thumbnail nicht. Und ich glaube, Dune 2, das macht ja mit einem richtig guten Film aus, funktioniert auch, das werde ich jetzt in jeder Filmkritik lesen, funktioniert der Kinofilm auf einem kleinen Bildschirm genauso gut. Ein guter Film muss auch funktionieren, wenn man ihn im Flugzeug auf dem Bildschirm des Vordermanns ohne Ton sieht. Genau. Und man dann sagt, wow! Und wirklich so, dann weiss man, okay, das ist ein guter Film. Wenn du wirklich so auf dem Sitz stehst und wirklich denkst, okay, was passiert jetzt? Und wirklich Angst hast, Schreie, Lachen. Du hast irgendwie vergessen, du wolltest entweder den Flug raw doggen. Meine Frage ist, geht das überhaupt in einem Flugzeug, wo jeder sitzt vor sich, hat irgendwie geguckt was? Klar, raw doggst du, meinet, du guckst neben dir Pixar-Film. Genau, raw dog bedeutet, dass man sich komplett jeder Unterhaltung entzieht. Man nimmt nichts mit, kein Magazin, nicht die bunte, nicht die illo, nicht den Spiegel und man starrt einfach vor sich hin als Exegese, als Eremitentum und man entzieht sich alle Stimulanz und ist natürlich die Frage, ist es so wie bei der Tour de France, weil ich meine, offenes Geheimnis, Tour de France, da kann keiner Fahrrad fahren. Ich dachte, bei Tour de France gucken, das ist für mich auch die reinste Exegese. Kann auch keiner Fahrrad fahren. Was die machen ist, immer wenn die Kamera wegschneidet, dann kommt ein Auto und schiebt da mal an. Nimmt mal die Hand und schiebt den Fahrrad an. Mit so einer Gabel, diese SchaffelbordDinger. Mit so einem grossen Schieber.
Und die haben halt genau auf dem Handy, so stelle ich es mir vor, im Auto haben die das Handy offen.
Und dann fährt halt da der Lance Morris nebenan und dann so, ja, tritt, tritt, tritt, tritt.
Und dann, so, jetzt schneiden sie weg, hol den Schieber raus, schieben.
Ja.
So, und nur, dass es halt niemand sieht, weil ich meine, die Strecke ist super lang, das kann niemand kontrollieren.
Und so, denke ich, ist es mit diesen Raw-Dogging-Trends auch, dass die Leute sagen, ich bin jetzt Raw-Dogger. Ich mach das, genau, solange ich mich vlogge. Richtig. Aber dann freue ich mich auch, du vloggst dich beim Raw-Doggen. Ja. Du machst dir, du schaffst dir Dinge drauf. Ich will, die richtigen Raw-Dogger, von denen wissen wir ja gar nicht, weil die fucking Raw-Doggen, und es gibt ja Raw-Dogger gerade in der ältesten Generation, die im ICE Raw-Doggen, und die, ich finde, es sollte verboten werden, weil es einen einfach wahnsinnig macht, wenn man neben Raw Dogger sitzt. Absolut, ich sitze da, ich schaue irgendwie meine YouTube-Videos und denke mir, ich könnte nicht raw doggen, wie der mich gerade raw doggt. Und der raw doggt und er registriert mich nicht mal, er sieht mich nicht mal. Mathilde, 64 nebenan, raw doggt the shit out of me. Die raw doggt mich so hart von der Seite weg. Und ich denke mir, ich könnte in drei Jahren drei Jahren nicht so raw doggen. Wenn ich jetzt anfangen würde zu raw doggen, wäre ich in drei Jahren nicht auf dem Leben. Ich wäre in drei Jahren nicht so weit. Und die ist 64, die hat wahrscheinlich ihr Leben lang geraw dogt. Die ist so erfahren, ich bin so unerfahren. Absolut. Und das ist natürlich ein Problem, aber ich glaube, dass diese Raw Dogger, von denen man so viel hört, die haben ein komplettes Team. Also die haben natürlich ein Team und du hast natürlich dann vor denen hast du Leute sitzen mit Bildschirmen an,
du hast vorne Leute, die Musik spielen nach hinten.
Also ich glaube, ich will jetzt nicht das jedem Raw Dogger
wirklich unterstellen, aber ich glaube, dass du das einfach
nur mit einem Team schaffst.
Ja, es ist Ende des Jahres, wir können die Thesen raushauen,
das ist jetzt so Rückblick.
Raw Dogging ist Fake, Geogasting ist Fake.
Geogasting ist Fake.
Beides Fake, Fake, Fake, Fake.
Woher sollen die im Wald wissen, wo sie sind? Fake, Fake, Fake. Funktioniert nicht. Wir rufen alle Fake, fake, fake. Fake, fake, fake. Jeder, jeder Fake wird jetzt noch am Ende entlarvt, weil wir sind ja jetzt, glaube ich, und das ist nämlich meine Theorie, ich bin nämlich in Weihnachtsstimmung und, also man merkt es, glaube ich, man sieht es auch. Woran? Dass ich vier Kilo zugenommen habe. Und das ist ja meine, ich fragge mich ja immer, jetzt natürlich heisst das Thema Spotify, Rapped, das Jahr ist quasi abgeschlossen. It's a rap! Aber man denkt sich, Moment mal, mein Blick auf den Chronometer zeigt, da ist es nicht vorbei. Was passiert, fließt das, was ich jetzt höre, in mein nächstes Jahr? Und ich glaube nein, weil sonst hätte ich jedes Jahr als Album Nummer eins Michael Bublé die Weihnachtshits. Deswegen habe ich ja bei Twitter, als es noch cool war, als es noch gab, habe ich immer getwittert, jetzt könnt ihr hören, was ihr wollt, weil jetzt müsst ihr euch nicht schämen, dass ihr einen peinlichen Spotify rappt habt. Genau. Das ist diese schöne Zeit im Jahr, wo ich mich unbeobachtet fühle und die ganze Zeit Defying Gravity hören kann. Ja, ich habe jetzt schon mehr Michael Bublé gehört, als ich mein Top-Album It's beginning to look a lot like Christmas. Aber es ist mich so wahnsinnig. Every God damn year. Ganz kurz, ich hasse Michael Bublé. Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, weißt du warum? Da war jemand ein Problem. Ich weiß nicht, ob dir das auch so geht, aber es gibt so manche. Ich fordere dich zu einem Wrestling-Match auf deinem perfekt gemachten Hotelbett heraus. Wir gegeneinander oder Michael Bublé? Lass uns das jetzt ein für alle mal klären. Wir beiden? Wir wrestlen. Aber ohne Shirts. Ohne Shirts, wir wrestlen, aber mit Kissen. Okay, mit Kissen. Ohne Shirts, ohne Hosen, mit Kissen. Ohne Shirts, ohne Hosen, mit Socken und mit. Ja, mit Socken und Kissen. Weil da möchte ich gegen dich kämpfen. Ich habe den Drang, gegen dich zu kämpfen, ich spüre Aktion. Wenn du sagst, Michael Bublé... patreon.com slash das Podcast UFO oder onlyfans.com slash das Podcast UFO. Könnt ihr unseren 40-sekündigen Kampf, weil wir nach 20 Sekunden alle komplett hechelnd am Boden liegen, im Sinne von Erschöpfung, weil wir das nicht aufrechterhalten können. Im Sinne von Rough Sex.
Nein.
Also, schaut rein.
Weil, pass auf, was mich nämlich so stört, ich glaube, das geht dir auch so, weil Michael Bublé versucht in jeder Zeile zu zeigen, dass er besser ist als alle anderen Sänger im Radio. Du sagst es Mariah Carey-Syndrom. Nee, genau, und zwar bei ihm ist es nämlich nicht diese Verkünstelung, was diese diese ganzen genau, diese Glissandier Arpeggios. Die Christina Aguilera. Genau. Bei Michael Bublé ist es You better watch out, you better not cry. Dieses, weißt du, dieses, er singt nicht auf dem Takt. Das nennt man Rubato, das ist ganz normal, das ist in der Musik angekommen. Ich will ja den Song, wenn ich den im Radio ein Jahr nicht gehört habe. Will ich ja, you better watch out, you better not cry. Ich will doch den auf dem Punkt haben. Aber Michael Bublé ist besser als das. Er ist besser als wir. Er singt nicht You better not cry. Er singt You better not cry. Und man denkt so, fuck die Attitude. Nein, Michael Bublé ist ein Sänger für Fortgeschrittene, die den Standardkram kennen, die jetzt die Variation wollen, die ein bisschen Pepp wollen, die ein bisschen Pfeffer mit rein wollen, die einfach sagen, okay, ich gehe da rein. Es ist mit viel Pfeffer, es ist over seasoned, es ist dieses Michael Bublé ist der Karottenkuchen. He's checking it twice. He's gonna find out who's naughty. Michael Bublé, er lässt nicht warten, er zieht, er gibt, er gibt dir ein bisschen was, aber das Orchester macht das ja nicht. Das Orchester, diese riesen geile Big Ben im Hintergrund, die macht es ja on point. Und er swingt da den Shit raus. Der Bubler ist unterm Strich, unterm Strich ist der Bubler aber wieder auf null. Er ist der Bubler, aber die Bubler sind tatsächlich die Fans. Ich persönlich würde mich auch als einer von die Bubler bezeichnen. Ich finde, es ist Distinktion, also Abgrenzung. Er ist der besser ausgebildete Sänger, hat dann diese Big Band, diese klassische E-Musik Attitude und er will, er weiß, er läuft bei WDR4. Meinst du wirklich, Michael Bublé, wenn er zum Mikrofon greift, denkt sich, I'm gonna sing for WDR4. WDR4, er weiss, ich glaube auf WDR4, da läuft auch im Zweifels bei der Murphy Gangs Skandal im Schwärbezirk. So, aber er will zeigen, ah nee, ich bin immer noch der Bubler, ich bin was Besseres. Richtig, aber ich finde, das ist ein guter Ansatz, dass du auch dem WDR-Publikum mal so ein bisschen eine gewisse musikalische Kreativität anhandelst. Ja, aber ist meine Frage, ist es denn so wahnsinnig kreativ, einfach alles ein bisschen zu spät zu singen? Das ist jetzt, nee, das ist verknappt, das ist verkünzelt.
Ich würde die Spur nehmen und nach vorne schieben und der Song klingt besser.
Nee, das spricht auch ein bisschen Neid aus der Haus, weil er dich damals im X-Faktor besiegt hat.
Michael Guglick.
Er lässt sich warten, er lässt sich warten, er lässt sich warten.
Aber ich meine, ich ist...
He's gonna find out who's naughty and...
Nice. Er lässt sich warten. Aber ich meine... He's gonna find out who's naughty and...
Nice.
Fick dich.
Ich finde das überhaupt richtig kacke.
Sing den Song so gut es geht.
Ich weiß, dass du danach den Takt halten kannst,
auch wenn du Cry oder Naughty or Nice zu spät singst.
Er macht den Song zu seinem eigenen. Ich finde, das ist die Botschaft von Weihnachten.
Weihnachten ist für jeden was anderes. Jeder hat eine andere Art von Weihnachten. Das ist das Traditionsreichste. Alles ist gleich, alle machen das gleich an Weihnachten. Ja, das stimmt nicht. Ich komme hier zum Beispiel rein und finde eine halb aufgegessene Packung Dominosteine. Und ich denke mir, ja, ja, Stefan Tietze geniesst Weihnachten auf seine Art. Nicht jeder sitzt in einem Hotel in Essen und knabbert die Dominosteine. Wenn du unterjährig bei mir Dominosteine findest, würde ich sagen, okay, krass, Individualist, awesome. Aber du findest Weihnachten mit Dominosteine. Da würde ich sagen, okay, einfach komm vor mir. Nein, es gibt Vanillekipferl, es gibt Zimtsterne, es gibt so viele Variationen zu Weihnachten, dass jeder was haben kann. Aber ärgert dich, dass der Begriff Dominosteine so überhaupt gar keinen Sinn ergibt? weil es Würfel sind und man immer denkt so, ich will die aneinander rein, ich will die umstoßen, Domino Day. Eigentlich W6, ja. Nicht Dominosteine, das ist was anderes. Dominowürfel eigentlich. Oder halt einfach Würfelwürfel. Diese klassischen Printen sehen viel mehr aus wie Dominosteine. Ja, stell dir vor, Dominoday wird Product Pl Placement Dominostein. Desaster! Absolutes Desaster! Funktioniert überhaupt nicht. Oh, hier ist nicht viel gefallen. Gar nicht viel gefallen. Hier ist überhaupt nichts gefallen. Oh, das Bild ist... Es hätte sehr viel fallen sollen, es wurde nichts, es ist nichts gefallen. Wir können ja ahnen, vielleicht ist es Santa Claus, sollte es sein, wir wissen es nicht, es steht alles noch in Dominostein. Alle Domsteine sind nicht gefallen. Im nächsten Bild soll viel fallen, hier ist nicht viel gefallen. Oh, ist das eine Taube? Anfang der 2000er. Ich habe auch jetzt irgendwie, wurde nochmal so die erste DSDS-Staffel bei mir überall reingespielt, auf allen Kanälen. Okay. Weiß auch nicht, wie das passiert ist. Aber natürlich, das war, was wir da reingezogen haben. Early 2000s, wirklich Nostalgiewochen, Weihnachten, jetzt mehr. Domino Day, wenn das noch zu Weihnachten liefe,
das wäre der absolute Overkill an Nostalgie.
Das wäre der absolute Overkill. Früher ist viel gefallen,
jetzt bei diesem Feld ist nicht viel gefallen, wir gucken, was noch fallen wird.
Moment, ist das eine Taube?
Oh, wir haben eine Taube in der Halle.
Ah ja, das war wirklich mal ein Spatz in der Halle.
Ja, ein Spatz in der Taube.
Riesenproblem.
Ich sag mal, lieber ein Spatz in der Halle als eine Taube auf dem Dach.
So, und dann hast du natürlich ein Riesenproblem, weil natürlich, ich meine, das ist natürlich die bittere Realität, aber natürlich wird der Spatz getötet. Also der muss entnommen werden. Weil hier sonst nichts fällt, muss der Spatz fallen. Der muss natürlich im richtigen Moment, wenn er über nichts Wichtiges fliegt, muss er liquidiert, also exekutiert. Und da gibt es Scharfschützen, das sind natürlich Scharfschützen, die ihn direkt raw doggen, also wirklich bei erster Sicht einfach trigger happy. Diese Forschung ist, der Domino Day Scharfschützen hat, die auch dann so ein süße Logo auf dem Sweater haben. Genau, ja, klar. Aber ich meine, klar, du hast beim Dominoday hast du ja Flitzer, das ist ja klar.
Es ist ja klar, dass da Leute eindringen, die sich da in die Dominos werfen wollen, die müssen natürlich ausgeschaltet werden, wie der Uruk-Kai bei Helms-Klamm. Sehr logisch. Das ist ganz klar. Wo wir gerade bei schön bestickten Sweatern sind, das erinnert mich an unser Merch. Denn wir freuen uns sehr, wir haben neues Merch an den Start gebracht. Man unterscheidet ja, auch wir sind ja transparente Podcast, deswegen sage ich, dass wir unterscheiden ja zwischen so Drops, fancy, weirde Motive, die dann aber auch limitiert sind oder so, und so Basic Merch, einfach was immer erhältlich ist. Der Cheeseburger bei McDonalds. Genau. Wir reden nicht vom Big Rösti, wir reden nicht vom Raclette-Burger. Wir reden nicht vom Filet-Fisch. Doch, wir reden vom Filet-Fisch, von den Standard-Satzen, die immer mit dabei sind. Wir reden nicht vom Sunday Flushy, McFlush. Okay, es gibt alles nicht. aber der McRib war früher ein Standard und jetzt mittlerweile ist er ein Aktionsprodukt, aber wir reden, sagen wir Monopoly. Monopoly ist Event, ist besonders, aber aktuell. Ist das nicht immer? Ist das nicht immer, nein, wir reden jetzt vom Sechser-Checkback-Nuggets, die gibt's immer, egal um wie viel Uhr du da auftauchst, die haben immer holt mich ab. Wir haben immer noch ein paar Hühner im Gefrierfach. Ja, ich war jetzt bei Burger King. Ja, alles klar. Footlong. Oder so ein Bucket. So, davon rede ich. Die klassische Margarita. Die ist immer da. Margarita, der Drink. Die sind immer da. Die sind immer da. Und das ist jetzt genau auch unser Merchstop, nämlich das Podcast-Ufo-Podcast-Projekt mit ganz tollen Motiven. Genau, mit ganz tollen Motiven. Schaut mal rein, die sind toll bestickt, die sind geil gedruckt. Das war uns sehr wichtig, dass sie cool aussehen. Ich finde, wir haben eine coole Sache. Der Schale ist schon ausverkauft, das hat mich sehr überrascht. Die Leutniskeit, die Leutniskeit, die brauchen Schal. Genau, schaut mal rein, der wird bald wieder aufgestockt. Schaut mal rein, um die neuen Basic-Merge, Basic klingt so, als wäre es so unsere neuen Basic-Scheiss. Die Grundlage, jeder braucht auch Grundlagen-Merge, das kann man immer tragen. Genau, wenn ihr Ufo-Club-Mitglieder seid, dann kriegt ihr sogar 10% auf jedes Merch. Lasst euch diesen Rabatt nicht entgehen,
liebe UFO-Clubber.
Ansonsten müssen wir natürlich die Podcast-Ufo-Scharfschützen,
die in der Nähe sind,
euch leider... Mit diesem süßen UFO-Stick
vorne drauf. Genau, mit dem Schal, die
tragenden Schal, die sind in ganz nackt draußen. Mal ein bisschen
mehr Liebe für Schafschützen, okay? Haut mal
ein bisschen Liebe in den Chat. Haut mal ein bisschen Liebe in den Chat
für Schafschützen, für Mörder und Täter. Die meisten Scharfschützen schießen ja kein einziges Mal in ihrem Leben. Das ist ja wie ich damals beim Karate. Stille Helden. Du hast den 15-jährigen Florentin massiv übergewichtig, schön den Nintendo DS in der Tasche. Und dann sagt dein Karatelehrer, wir lernen Karate, um es nie anzuwenden. Und Florentin hinterfragt alles. Warum bin ich so fett? Warum bin ich der Einzige, der hier keinen einzigen Lügelschnitts machen kann? Und warum bin ich hier, wenn ich es nie anwenden soll? Und tatsächlich, mein Sensei hatte Recht behalten, denn ich habe Karate gelernt und es bis heute nie angewendet. Oder sagst du nur, dass du es gelernt hast? Es ist, wie ich letzte Woche gesagt habe, lass uns allen Schülerinnen der sechsten Klassen Revolver geben. Ja. Ihr habt alle gehofft, dass ich das nie wieder sage. Da kam ein Backlash, da kam tatsächlich ein paar Lehrerinnen und Lehrer haben sich da gemeldet und meinten, das sei keine gute Idee. Hast du ein Statement vorbereitet? Nee, ich bin double downing. Okay, also zwei Revolver. Jedes Kind gibt zwei Revolver, in jeder Hand ein Revolver. Nice, sehr gut. Zwei Halfter, Holster, Halster. Das weiß ich auch immer nicht. Holfter, Halster, Holster. Halfter? Ja. Einfach von Halfter, Halster. Das sind Dinge, die wegfallen. Die gibt es irgendwann nicht mehr. Bitte, genau, bewaffnet euch bis an die Zähne. Also quasi immer einer mehr wie du. Ist ja da die Regel, der goldene Satz, der gilt. Ja. Ja, ihr habt alle gehofft, dass ich das nie wieder anspreche, aber es ist nach wie vor in meinem Kopf. Und nach wie vor denke ich, das ist ja wie du, der behauptet, du hast Karate gelernt. Ja. Oder vielleicht hast du es sogar gelernt, als abschreckende Wirkung. Ich habe es gelernt, ich habe es bis zum Orangengürtel geschafft und das sind für mich die Basics, das reicht für mich. Das ist der zweite Gürtel. Die wichtigsten Tritte und Hiebe sind drin, aber ich würde sogar auch noch Doppeldown und würde sagen, jedes Kind zwei Revolver und ein Breitschwert. Ich sage lieber mittelalterlich. Mittelalterlich ausrüsten. Jedes Kind kriegt ein Breitschwert. Weil die haben ja schon einen riesen Turnister auf dem Rücken. Die haben einen Turnister, die brauchen jetzt zwei Holster und eine Scheide.. Eine breite Scheide. Die brauchen eine breite Scheide für ein Breitschwert und dann trägt jedes Kind eine breite Scheide mit sich rum. Breite Scheide, halfter oder holster, halfter, ist glaube ich mit dem Pferd, bin mir auch nicht sicher. Und dann haben die so ein Riesenschwert hinten so am Rücken, was dann so unten über den Boden schafft. Oh ja ja, das klingt dann so durch die Welt wie bei Zelda. Es ist aber wichtig, es ist wirklich wichtig, unsere Kinder bis an die Zähne zu bewaffnen. Ja, das ist ja Dune, das dachte ich ja bei Dune. Bei Dune haben die ja so Schilder, dass die keine Schusswaffen haben. Deswegen müssen die alle albern mit Nahkampfwaffen rumhampeln, was ja für jeden Science-Fiction-Universums-Autor immer so schwierig ist. Nahkampfwaffen sind einfach cooler. Warum sollten die das überhaupt noch machen? So bei Space Marines mit diesen Kettensägenschwertern und so, Lichtschwerden und manche einfach rum, aber die haben dann irgendwas cooles, besonderes oder die Macht oder so und bei Dune einfach, ne, fuck it, einfach alle Schusswaffen raus, alle haben Nahkampfwaffen, vielleicht sollten wir wieder mehr in die Richtung. Aber bei Dune fand ich es gut erklärt, es gibt einfach Schilde, es gibt Schilde, ja. Wobei ... Die halten alles auf, was schnell ist.
Das heißt, da würde ich als Karatekämpfer wieder brillieren,
weil ich war besonders bekannt dafür, sehr langsam anzugreifen.
Das heißt, wo mein Sensei scheitern würde, der schlägt zu schnell,
der hatte diesen Aspekt der Tausend Hiebe gewählt,
wo du noch mal Bonusangriffskraft kriegst,
wenn du mehrere Treffer hintereinander landest.
Wohin ging ich, hatte den Aspekt des Faultiers. Duinander landest. Wohingegen ich hatte den Aspekt des Faultiers.
Ich hatte den Aspekt des Faultiers gewählt,
wo du nicht so schnell angreifst,
aber dafür dreifachen Schaden machst. Du kritest immer,
du kritest jedes Mal. Faultiere aber nicht dafür bekannt,
dreifachen Schaden zu machen. Wenn sie mal
treffen schon. Hast du die Klauen gesehen?
Hast du die Krallen gesehen? Ja. Was bringen
die Krallen? Die haben die nur damit, die da hängen,
an dem Baum hängen. Ich finde die so faszinierend. Faszinosum Sloths. Ja. Ein Infantier, das sich leisten kann, so langsam zu sein und sagt, ich lebe noch. Ha? Ha? Natur, Evolution, Survival of the fittest, Survival of the slowest. So würden die ja gar nicht reden, die würden sagen, ha, die würden wie Michael Bublé singen.
Seht ihr, was sagt ihr jetzt?
Das Faultier.
Ich lebe noch, motherfuckers, bitches, ich lebe noch. Der langsamste Mittelfinger der Natur, Ein faszinierendes Wesen.
Stark, stark.
Aber die hängen rum, die hängen richtig rum.
Die hängen rum und ... Die hängen teilweise ineinander rum.
Es gibt ja auch dieses Spiel, diese Faultiere, die man so ineinander hängt.
Ah ja.
Weil ja dieses eine Faultier und das andere kann sich ja nicht wehren, dass es da dran hängt.
Das ist doch mein Kindergartenspiel gewesen.
Diese Affen, die man so ineinander hängt.
Ja, diese Klemmaffen. Das fand ich ja mega geil. Am Ende hängt man sich selber dran und dann guckt man, ob es hält oder nicht. Generell, warum darf ich als Erwachsener nicht Brettspiele spielen, wo ein bisschen mehr Formel passiert, als man legt Chips oder man legt Karten irgendwo hin. Okay, du bist dann eher so der Doktor-Krock-Typ. Doktor-Bibber, Doktor-Crocks, wir reden von den Doktors. Ja, wir sind im medizinischen Bereich. Ich will Dinge hinhängen. Ich will grosse, ich will, kann man jemanden Spieler finden mit so grossem, weiß nicht, so einem Baum, Wald, Park von mir. So, und jetzt aber, okay, Dominote ist tot, damit müssen wir leben, kein Problem, wurde geraw-dogged, ist weg. So, jetzt aber, ich sage, Kletterhafen-Tag. Wir mieten eine Halle, holen uns wirklich tonnenweise von diesen kleinen Plastikäffchen und versuchen, wie viele von diesen Plastikäffchen können wir an einen Baum hängen. Riesiger Plastikbaum in der Mitte der Halle, es treten auf Chris Ed Sheeran, Michael Bublé, ein Freund von dir, der hat mich gebeten, dass ich ihn mal erwähne im Podcast. Liebe Grüße, Chris. Chris? Ich glaube, du wirst diese große Keine. Also, er heißt Christian, aber er nennt sich selbst Chris und ich habe da auch nichts dagegen. Das ist völlig in Ordnung. Chris mit ZZ? Wenn er sich einzettet, ja, tatsächlich. Aber ich nenne ihn einfach, es ist okay. Ich finde, jeder hat das Recht, sich selbst den Namen zu geben. Kurz, ich weiss, Weihnachten sind alle lieb zueinander, wir haben uns alle lieb, Küsschen auf die Stirn, aber wenn ihr euch einen Spitznamen gebt, mit einem Z drin, sauer und cool. Wenn in eurem Namen kein Z drin ist und die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist hoch, dass kein fucking Z zu finden ist. Und alle fünf Zacharias gerade legen das Handy wütend weg. Ja, die Zoe's und die Zacharias's. Aber, wenn ihr Chris heisst, und dann ist aber Chris mit Z, Z wie Riz, Chris at gmail.com und ist eure fucking Adresse at web.de, Chris at web.de. Ich habe ein bisschen Respekt davor. Ich finde das okay. Ich finde zwei Z, also wenn dann ein Z oder drei Z. Zwei Z ist immer so ein bisschen, das ist wie wenn man mit zwei Punkten endet. So, hey, treffen wir uns morgen noch? Punkt, Punkt, Punkt, Fragezeichen. Was, wo sind wir gerade? Ja, zwei Z finde ich zu wenig. Drei Z ist dann schon wieder Triple X, so Triple Z, da bist du irgendwie dabei. B, W, W, Drei sind immer irgendwie eine Einheit. Aber zwei finde ich immer zu wenig. Das heißt, du heisst Chrissy. Bei Chrissy, da ist natürlich wieder alles möglich, das ist klar. Ja, die Top drei der Zahlen, eins bis drei, ist die zwei ganz unten, die drei oben und die eins in der Mitte. Eins in der Mitte, ganz klar. Aber die drei ist die beste Zahl, die Top drei. Die Top zwei, ja. Ich stelle mir vor, Ralf Schmitz moderiert das Ganze. Das haben wir schon fast gedacht. Oder halt Matthias Oppenhövel. Ich denke eher Ninja Warriors. Ah, Wontorra, Laura Wontorra. Laura Wontorra, Jan Köppen. Jan Köppen, oh okay, sowas Actionreiches. Wir können ja auch zwei Moderationslager haben. Einmal so eher die Entertainment-Sparte, Matthias Oppenhövel, und Laura Wontorra, die dann eher so aus der Sport-Ecke kommt. Und dann kann man immer hin und her switchen zwischen beiden. Aber generell stelle ich mir vor, du hast einen riesigen Plastikbaum in der Halle. Und dann kommen Promis, die immer wieder ein Äffchen dranhängen und so. Und das machst du wirklich stundenlang. Die Länge ist immer kein Qualitätsmerkmal. Irgendwann sagt der Regisseur, okay, wir sind jetzt seit zwei Stunden, wir haben hundert Äffchen hingehängt. Ich habe aber eine Idee für ein Interval Act. Intervall Act? Ja. Ich wrestle gegen Michael Bublé auf so ein Deathmatch. Ja, okay. Mit Breitschwertern kriegt jeder ein Breitschwert oder wie läuft das dann auf Ende? Ja. Ja. Du willst ihn einfach mal töten, du willst einfach mal am Ende sagen, okay, es hat sich ausgebubbelt. Das Ding ist, das Album steht, du wirst es nicht begraben können. Sumoring gegen Michael Bublé, ich und Michael Bublé gegeneinander. Sumoring gegen Michael Bublé, aber ihr seid ja beide, jetzt sag ich mal, eher schlanker Natur, oder nicht? Aus meinem näheren Umfeld dreht jemand um ein paar Ecken mit Sumoringern bald und hatte deswegen Kontakt zu Japanern, Japanerinnen und dann fiel der Satz im Gespräch todernst und seitdem hängt er in meinem Kopf, Sumoringer, ja, they hold a lot of power. und ich denke das ist ja insane ja there is a lot of power. Und ich denke, das ist ja insane.
Ja.
There is a lot of power to them.
Oder wie gesagt, they hold a lot of power.
Sie haben eine Menge Macht inne.
Ja, sie haben eine Menge Macht inne.
Und das ist doch fantastisch.
Das ist schon geil, ja.
Wie mystisch. Und wahrscheinlich sind es sehr gut bezahlte Sportler, Sportlerinnen. Auf jeden Fall. Aber ich frage mich, warum? Das ist so ein ganz langer Prozess auch. Du musst da in so einem Trainingsdojo-Kloster anfangen irgendwie und musst dich dann da hinarbeiten oder so und dann nur ganz wenige schaffens und so. Das ist schon ganz krass. Fand ich mega geil, war so mystisch. Ja, diese Mystik ist ja genau weg. They hold a lot of power. Ja, oder Esoterik. Du meinst jetzt, wenn du so an so einen Mike Tyson denkst. Ja, ich denke an so einen Joshua Kimmich. Oder so einen Niklas Süle, weiß nicht warum. So Sportler. Du meinst, die haben nicht so viel Macht inne. So Kai Havertz, so Jamal Musiala. Ja. Da sagt das niemand,
they hold a lot of power.
Ja, gut, die machen halt Werbung für Chips.
Das ist halt ein Understanding.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Sumoringer auch
dann so Werbeikonen sind, die dann wirklich Werbung machen
oder irgendwie in der Öffentlichkeit stehen
oder ob das wirklich wie so spirituelle
Mittelpunkte sind oder einfach so
Ja, ist das so religiös?
Also ist das auch eine ganze Ich weiß, hat das was mit Buddha zu tun? Keine Ahnung, ich bin da gar nicht drin. Konfuzio, ich weiss ich nicht, glaube ich. Aber es hat natürlich so ein bisschen so einen Eso-Anstrich, so einen spirituellen Anstrich. Ja, oder gibt man denen das so aus Marketinggründen? Ich meine, das wird ja auch irgendwie eine ganz krasse Martial-Arts-Nummer sein oder so. Es gibt ja Mixed Martial Arts, wo verschiedene Kampfsportarten geirneinander antreten. Wo ist der Sumo-Ringer? Hat der eine Chance gegen so einen Muay Thai, gegen so einen Banh-Mi-Kämpfer, der da auftaucht und den umhauen will? Ich weiß es nicht. Genau. Ich glaube, die machen da gar nicht mit, weil they hold a lot of power. Ja. Die sind in ihren Tempeln, irgendwo auf so Riesenbergen. Die haben das gar nicht nötig. Stell ich mir vor, dass sie da oben, aber sie sieht man so ein Licht abends an. Und dann geht es aber auch ganz schnell wieder aus. Und wenn man hinguckt, dann geht es wieder an und wieder ganz schnell aus. Steht jemand im Schalter, dann kommt man aus, und man denkt sich, ja, vielleicht müssen sie das gerade machen. Ja, ja, das wird von ihnen erwartet. Du musst natürlich auch viele Erwartungen erfüllen als Zoom-Ringer. Du kannst ja nicht in der Öffentlichkeit auftauchen und dir immer Superman angucken im Kino. Aber Mixed Martial Arts, wenn man aber näher hinschaut, so wirklich mixt ist es nicht. Nee, es ist kein Salat. Es ist kein herrlicher Garten. Es ist kein gutes Buffet. Nee. Du hast, wo ist Capoeira? Wo ist Fechten? Capoeira ist ein Tanz. Äh, Capoeira ist ein Kampftanz. Es ist kein Tanzkampf. Es ist mehr Tanz als Kampftanz. Es ist weniger Kampf als Tanz. 60-40. Okay. Siehst du, es werden Deals geschlossen am Ende des Jahres. Das Kalenderjahr ist vorbei. Ich glaube, die meisten Deals werden Ende des Jahres geschlossen, weil Leute sagen, ich will weg hier, ich habe keinen Bock mehr, ich will nach Hause, ich will den Bubler hören. Und dann sind sie raus. Aber Mixed Martial Arts, mir fehlen die Fechter, mir fehlt dieser Langstab, mir fehlen diese kleinen Messer. Revolver, mir fehlen die sechstjährigen Mädels mit den Revolvern, mit den bis zum Ende geladenen Revolvern. Oh, da sind richtig viele Patronen drin. Ich will, dass dieser türkische Olympionike, der so cool, so einen Nonchalon geschossen hat mit der Hand in der Hose.
Ach ja, genau.
Der so hochgesprochen ist, der Schütz, dieser Pistolenmann, der soll, das ist für mich Mixed Martial Arts.
Ja, das ist Mixed.
Der soll gegen, jetzt sag mal so einen klassen.
Der gegen so einen Sumoringer, ja.
Oder so einen, wie heißt das dann, Tretmann. Der kämpft gegen Tretmann. Das ist doch mal wirklich mixt. Das ist wirklich mal eine Mischung. Da weiss man nicht, was einen erwartet. Wie heißt das denn? Das ist wirklich Tropi Frotti. Kickboxen. Taekwondo, ach so. Kickboxen. Tretschlagen, zu deutsch.
Der, die gegen so diesen Türken
mit der Waffe. Geil. Genau, und dann aber
hätte ich noch gerne drin so einen Strategen.
So eine Art Napoleon,
der so an so einem Strategietisch sitzt und der
irgendwie so dann taktisch
an die Sache rangeht. Dass man wirklich sagt,
mixt so das Frontschwein gegen irgendwie
so den Taktiker. Einfach mal gucken, was passiert.
So, das ist für mich wirklich mixt. Ja, Napoleon kriegt auf den Latz.
Na, weiß ich. Napoleon, glaube ich,
hätte sich schon was ausgedacht.
Aber der war auch nicht so klein, wie man dachte.
Der hätte sich dann so hingestellt, dass er hinter dem Scheinwerfer steht
und dann blendet der Scheinwerfer
den anderen Kämpfer und dann kann er ihn ausmachen.
Nein, wir alle wissen, wie fucking Napoleon
es gemacht hätte. Alle denken, er kommt von
links und dann kommt er von rechts.
Nach dem Film wäre das
seine Strategie. Genau. Oh alle denken, er kommt von links und er kommt von rechts.
Nach dem Film wäre das seine Strategie.
Oh krass, er kommt von rechts
und von schräg links.
Mike, Mike, Mike, er kommt auf jeden Fall von links.
Du musst einfach nur deine linke
Seite verteidigen.
Mike Tyson, einfach nur linke Flanke
hoch und dann haust du immer eine rein.
Okay, alles klar, du gehst da raus und machst ihn fertig, Tiger.
Ah, er kommt von rechts. Sacreble! Dir fällt die Masse hier ist nicht ein. Dir fällt die Nationale nicht ein. Du wolltest eigentlich immer sehr singen, ich kenne dich doch. Aber dir fällt nur dieses Lied ein. Wenn ich an Lieder denke, fällt mir dieses fucking Lied ein. Immer wenn ich ... So, und dann gewinnt Nappi am Ende doch diese ganzen alten, ich mein Klausewitz, ja, wir haben hier einen deutschen Napoleon, Klausewitz, Santa Klausewitz, wenn wir jetzt mal weihnachtlich dran sind. Das ist ein Nazi-Offizier? Nee, das ist doch der klassische vom Kriege Militärstratege, Grundlagen muss jeder gelesen haben, glaube ich, so Preussen gedöhnt war das. So, jetzt aber Santa Klausewitz. Meine Idee für eine Serie, Santa Klausewitz, ja, du hast Weihnachten ist die … Die Elfen, die rebellieren komplett gegen Santa Claus. Richtig, und Santa Clausewitz muss sich strategisch. Und dann sagt, Weihnachten ist die Fortsetzung der Politik mit anderen Mitteln. Und Weihnachtsmann zieht in den Krieg am Strategischen … Mit welcher mit seiner Rentierarmee? Mit seiner Rentierarmee, die Kavallerie hat er natürlich bestückt. Und so Schneeballkanonen. Schneeballkanonen und sein Schlitten ist natürlich das Flaggschiff quasi. Genau. Prescht er voran. Ja. Und das ist eine Serie, die trägt sich über mehrere Staffeln. Ja. Du sagst immer, dir fällt nichts ein für Serien. Hier hast du immer eine geile Serie. Du rufst mich immer an und sagst, ich habe keine Ideen. Ich habe keine Ideen mehr. Mir fällt nichts ein. Stimmt, so oft wie ich das anrufe. Das habe ich mir vorgegeben, dieses Jahr die weniger Anzug. Ja, vor allem nicht so spät und nicht so weinerlich immer so. Ich habe keine Ideen. Dann gebe ich ihm drei tolle Ideen. Nee, das will ich nicht. Das Ding, was du immer machst, du legst nicht auf, du gehst einfach weg vom Handy irgendwann, du setzt einfach irgendwann deinen Tag fort und das Handy liegt mit Telefonat auf, Stefan, Stefan, und du, dein Problem ist, dass du dann nicht auflegst und du bist dann dran und fragst, nach einer Stunde sehe ich, das Handy liegt dir noch an und Florian sagt immer noch Stefan, Stefan. Überleg nochmal,
Schneemänner, aber nicht
aus Schnee, sondern Kunstschnee.
Stell es dir vor,
aus unterschiedlichen, stell dir vor, es ist wie
Ninja Turtles. Aber Schneemann
und Schnee ist einfach ein Mann.
So, und jetzt kommen wir weiter. Vier Schneemänner,
alle, aber aus anderen
Sachen. Du hast einen Schneemann aus Lava.
Lava-Mann. Ja, Lava-Mann. Du hast einen Schneemann dann auch aus Schnee. Dein Körper rebelliert gegen diese Idee. Ein Schneemann ist klassisch aus Schnee, Frosty. Dann hast du einen Schneemann aus Teer. Dein Körper gibt dir klare Signale, dass es reicht. Dein Körper schaltet Stück für Stück Körperteile schon ab. Du hast einen Schneemann aus Thea und einen Schneemann aus Lianen. Wie willst du was beweisen? Nein, das sind vier verschiedene Schneemänner. Lava, Schnee, Thea und Dschungel. Dschungel und dann so Lianen. Dschungelmann. So, ja, Dschungelmann. Und dann haben die alle ihre drei Kugeln. Und dann, pass auf, können die sich immer zusammensetzen, weil du hast ja vier mal drei Kugeln, zwölf, und aus denen kannst du neue Dinge anordnen. Neun. Als Idee immer eine, ist ja nur eine Idee. Ja, aber du sagst immer so, das ist eine Idee, mach raus, was du willst, aber es ist schon konkret. Okay, es dreht niemand. So hängst du da immer im Handy. Und ich weiß nicht, kann ich jetzt auflegen, kann ich fortsetzen? Weißt du, was ich vermisse? Diese Schnur, diese dicken, wenn ich so Filme dieser Zeit spielen, wo es diese dicken Telefone gibt, diese dicken Plastik, diese dicken Hörer. Erstmal finde ich das so, hat das so eine ASMR-Haftigkeit, so eine wahnsinnige Faszination für mich, diese dicken Plastik, diese Muscheln. Und dann hängen die da so dran. Auch viel zu groß. Wenn man die aufschrauben würde, wäre da so ein winziger kleiner Lautspringer. Ja, ganz klein. Aber so ein dickes Plastik, oft dann so, weiß ich nicht, so grün, so khaki, weird Farben. Genau, ja. Und dann hast du so eine Schnur, die so gekringelt ist, und da kann man sich da den Finger so durch, dann hat man so einen Telefonsessel, so eine Telefonecke. Diese Schnur war so fucking lang. Die war ja nur einigermaßen handhabbar, weil die so gekringelt ist. Die ist ja wirklich, also die, das habe ich teilweise, du konntest teilweise in einen anderen Raum gehen mit der Schnur, weil die so fucking lang war. Mein Problem war immer, wir hatten so ein kleines windiges Telefon, das da stand und du konntest nicht dran ziehen, weil das dann immer mitgekommen ist, dann ist es immer mitgeflogen und dann hat das mit dem Telefonkabel an der Wand gespannt und dann hing das Telefon quasi zappelnd in der Luft, auf der einen Seite Stecker in der Wand, anderen Seite ich am Hörer und dann bin ich im Nebenraum und währenddessen Dengel dieses Telefon so in der Luft, wenn mein Bruder nach Hause
Bälle und die Bälle aus
Dschungel und
Verstehst du, Santa Clausewitz, der ist
einerseits preußischer Militärstratege,
muss aber zu Weihnachten
und das Telefon vibriert in Angst
einfach in der Mitte des Raumes.
Und dann kam mein Bruder und hat dann aufgelegt.
Dein Bruder, ne? Arschloch. Jetzt sag ich's mal. Okay. Ist Weihnachten auch die Zeit? Wollen wir es aufarbeiten? Bitte nicht. Wollen wir es jetzt aufarbeiten? Wir arbeiten das wie echte Männer, arbeiten wir das nicht auf, sondern reden weiter über unsere Ideen mit dem Thermann. Wollen wir es auswresteln? Nein, wir erfinden Ideen, Thermann, aber wir reden, wir konzentrieren uns nicht auf die Probleme, die uns zu denen gebracht haben.
Ja, das gehört dazu, wenn du Brüder hast, dann wird natürlich auch manchmal so ein bisschen. Ich hätte halt gerne einen Bruder, der bei mir aufgelegt hat.
Du sagst Einzelkinder.
Einmal jemand aufgelegt bei mir, weißt du?
So, deswegen telefonierst du so lange, weil bei dir nie jemand aufgelegt hat.
Ich habe neulich gehört, dass Einzelkinder erkennt man daran, dass sie oft den Raum verlassen, ohne zu sagen, was sie jetzt machen. Oh. Weil, wenn man Geschwister hat, wird rausgesagt, ich gehe küsse aufs Klo. Okay. Man sagt, man kündigt an, wo man ist. Aber ich finde das weird. Es ist wie so eine Erzählerstimme, die dein Leben narrated. Ja, meanwhile. Und dann ging ich aufs Klo und dann wärst du in den Raum und denkst so, ja, Weirdo. Aber es ist natürlich in einem Haushalt bei mehreren Leuten recht sinnvoll, so Weasley-mäßig zu wissen, wer wann wo ist. Dass man Rechnung trägt und die anderen machen sich auch Sorgen um dich. Wenn du Einzelkind bist, niemand kümmert sich um dich. Wo du bist, ist eigentlich egal. Aber wenn du Brüder hast, dann so, ah, ich bin jetzt übrigens da, falls was ist. Also du sagst, Einzelkind ist schlecht. Nein, du sagst nicht, ich bin auf dem Klo, falls was ist. Du sagst, ich bin auf dem Klo, damit alle wissen, ah, okay, Klo ist besetzt. Ja, aber es gibt oft die Situation, ja, wo ist der denn? Und dann müssen die anderen sagen, wo der ist. Aber Einzelkind ist ja gut, streut überall rum wie so eine Katze. Niemand fragt. Also du sagst, Einzelkind ist schlecht? Nee, nicht unbedingt. Ich sag nur, nee, ganz im Gegenteil. Das ist ja auch immer dieses Klischee, Einzelkinder sind unsozialer, weil sie nicht heilen mussten, was auch immer, mit wenigen Leuten abgehangen haben in dem Leben. Gibt es aber auch andere Studien, die mir das Gegenteil sagen, nee, gerade weil du immer alleine bist, allein an Orte kommst, im Urlaub, keine Ahnung, bist du nicht mit deinen Brüdern, verbrüderst dich mit denen, du musst sozusagen, du bist ja auch auf der Suche nach gleichaltrigem Kontakt. Ah, okay. Dann gibt es sowas wie, ja, weil du immer mit deinen Eltern zu dritt abhängst, bist du schon sehr früh, also neigen die dann zu so einem Frühreifen da sein, weil weil sie halt immer Eltern als Peers wahrnehmen. Und dann, das macht sich auch wieder ein bisschen weird vielleicht, aber es gibt so, und dann denke ich mir auch, Plays-Psychologie auch einfach, es kann nur in Extrem funktionieren. Weil, wenn ich zum Beispiel Futterneid habe, was ich habe, wenn ich mit jemandem esse und man hat so einen Frühstücksbrunch.
Ein paar von den Dominus.
Nee.
Nur einen.
Nein!
Finger weg.
Das zum Beispiel wäre mir scheißegal.
Würde ich mich Freunde zu geben.
Aber bei so einem Brunch.
Und dann gibt es ein,
eine Konfitüre
Erdbeer und eine zum Beispiel Aprikose oder Kirsch oder Himbeer. Erdbeer braucht niemand. Und wenn dann mein Kumpel dann die Aprikose selbstverständlich sich nimmt, dann drehe ich durch. Und dann kann man natürlich sagen, ah ja, weil du Einzelkind bist, nie teilen musstest, nervt dich das so.
Man kann aber auch
genauso argumentieren, nee, mein
Kumpel mit den vielen Brüdern,
der musste ja immer kämpfen,
deswegen nimmt er sich das. Und deswegen kannst du ja immer
alles aus deiner Vergangenheit in
beide Richtungen argumentieren.
Und das lässt mich zweifeln,
ob nicht,
weil das zeigt mir, ja gut, man kann
alles in beide Extreme.
Also Überkompensation oder maximale Prägung.
Das sind die beiden Extreme.
Und dann ist man nirgendwo.
Oder die Psychologie sagt irgendwann, okay, pass auf,
wir haben jetzt genug Studien gemacht,
es ist einfach jeder Mensch anders.
Ja, genau.
Also es ist halt einfach sehr komplex.
Es ist halt einfach jeder Mensch sein eigener Kosmos.
Ja, und dann ist man wieder in so einem ...
Die Welt ist, wenn man genau guckt, dann wieder recht boring,
weil es so komplex ist.
Weil es so komplex ist, dass man es gar nicht genau erklären kann.
Ja, so schwierig.
Ja, wenn man sich richtig damit etwas beschäftigt,
dann ist es wieder super komplex.
Ja, na ja, gut.
Das ist schon ein bisschen langweilig,
aber Weihnachten macht trotzdem Spaß.
Ja, ja, ist super lustig.
Wenn es kalt ist, wenn es so richtig kalt ist
und man draußen ist und die Luft so kalt ist.
Aber ich mag das ja. Aber ich weiß nicht, wie es dir geht. Hier in Essen gerade habe ich so ein bisschen Downer. Liegt nicht an Essen. Aber der Himmel ist so verhangen seit Tagen. Hängt so eine dicke Wolkendecke. Und ich habe heute Morgen gedacht, ich habe die Sonne bestimmt eine Woche nicht mehr gesehen. Auch so Köln. Die ist abgehauen. In Hamburg hast du bestimmt mehr Sonne. Deswegen Pilot sein. Als Pilot bist du ja komplett unbehelligt von den ganzen Dingen. Alle sind traurig, du hebst ab und dann fliegst du wieder runter und alle sind wieder traurig und du so, hä, wieso denn Sonne, es ist ja mega Sonne überall. Ich fliege gesund den ganzen Tag, ich lag quasi komplett in der Sonne, ich musste Sonnencreme auftragen, weil du mit diesen ganzen kleinen Wurmenschen, glaube ich, wie die sie auch nennen, in der Aviatik, dann einfach da gar nichts mit zu tun hast, weil die so rumwürmen da unten in ihrem Sud, in ihrem Wolkensud und du einfach da drüber cruist. Du cruist einfach drüber. Ja, es sind komplette Seinsdimensionen, die für dich keine Auswirkungen hat, weil du einfach drüber bist.
Ja, sogar. Einfach drüber. Ja. So der erste Mensch, der irgendwie mal mit einem Heissluftballon durch die Wolken, weil du denkst ja, was ist über den Wolken? Ja, die Freiheit muss gänzenlos sein, klar, logisch, aber was genau ist da? Und dann guckst du da so oben raus, das muss schon geil, also Heissluftballon. Aber fliegen die durch die Wolken? Wenn es schlecht läuft, ja. Wenn die zu wenig Ballast mitgenommen haben, wenn die Leute zu leicht sind. Hast du dieses Video gesehen, wo jemand sich entpuppt bei einer Heissluftballonfahrt als Fallschirmspringer? Oh, und dann ausspringt. Dann wird es ein Anorak abnimmt, dann drunter kommt ein Fallschirm zutage und der
will springen und der
Heissluftoperator
wie sagt man,
das ist nicht Pilot, Heissluftfahrer
Jesus,
ich habe ein fliegendes Objekt,
Wetter kann mir nichts,
ich gewinne gegen
Gravitation und ich bin
ein Fahrer, wie ein
fucking Busfahrer. Ich fahre ein Heissluftballon, ein Riesengefährt, super gefährlich, super cool. Ja, aber du fährst den halt. Wie ich fahre den? Naja, weil das ist ja schon ein Gefährt. Aber nicht Pilot, aber wie viel kmh ist mein Pilot? Nee, Pilot bist du nicht. Wieso, aber ich fliege. Naja, wie schnell fliegst du, fünf kmh? Also ab zehn, ab zehn ist mein Pilot. Kommst du nie hin. Doch, manchmal, wenn so ein Windstoß kommt. Nicht konstant, nicht nicht Durchschutzgeschwindigkeit. Und ist der runtergesprungen oder wurde er aufgehalten? Nee, er wurde aufgehalten vom Heissluftballonfahrer. Wie fucking unangenehm ist denn diese weitere Heissluftballonfahrt? Stell dir vor, da klettert jemand raus, du hältst ihn gewaltsam zurück, irgendwann sagt er, okay, ich höre auf. Und dann musst du noch eineinhalb Stunden in diesem scheiß Heiss Ballon sein. Was ist für eine schreckliche Situation. Ich hab über tausend Sprünge, und der Typ so, scheißegal, sie springen jetzt hier nicht raus. Danke. Und dann so sind die eineinhalb Stunden geflogen, der musste dann noch so sagen, ja hier rechts sehen sie, das und das, den Harz und so. Mega unangenehm, der musste trotzdem trotzdem deine Tour so machen. Und dann landen die, das ist die schlimmste Vorstellung, du landest, und dann hast du da diesen Fallschirm immer noch so gefaltet in deinem Rucksack. Das ist so unverrichteter Dinge. Ja, Bewertung und ach Gott. Aber hat der wirklich gesagt, tausend Sprünge? Ich habe irgendwie mehr als tausend Sprünge, ja. Das heißt, wenn der, sagen wir mal, hundert Sprünge im Jahr macht, über zehn Jahre, jeden dritten Tag einen Fallschirmsprung, das ist bestimmt aufregend. Manche Leute sagen ja, jeden Morgen kalt duschen. Das hilft, um den Kreislauf in den Schwung zu bringen. Und er hat sich das, glaube ich, überlegt mit jeden Morgen einen Fallschirmsprung. den Kreislauf. Selbst jeden Tag sind es drei Jahre. Also, irgendwann ist es doch Arbeit, oder? This is my morning routine. I'm James McAllister. And listen, guys, everything you need to do is skyjumping. Every morning skyjumping for three years and I'm telling you, your life is going to be better. Und ist in einem Flugzeug in zehn Kilometer Your Your life is going to be better springt. Aber der achthundertste Sprung macht doch keinen Spaß mehr, oder? Der siebte macht keinen Spaß mehr. Also, wie viel? Der erste, okay, alles unter Prämisse, man findet es mega geil. Ja, man hat keine quälende Todesangst. Ich hatte schon am ersten Sprung keine Angst,
würde denken, das ist alles Nonsens.
Aber so, wenn du richtig Bock drauf hast,
der Erste mega geil, Zweite mega geil,
im Dritten denkst du, ah, langsam möchte ich den Dreh raus, cool.
Beim Vierten denkst du, ist auch schon einfach oft das Gleiche.
Beim Fünften denkst du, ah, die fünf Voll machen, geil, aber reicht.
Beim Sechsten denkst du, was mach ich hier? Beim Siebten denkst du, es reicht. Das ist zu viel jetzt. Und er hat dann noch tausend. Tausend? Ich habe fast nichts in meinem Leben tausend Mal gemacht. Ich glaube, ich habe mir nicht mal tausend Mal die Zähne geputzt. Wie viel es gibt diese Regel, wenn du zehntausend Stunden in etwas hast, bist du gut darin. So kann man sagen, das Leben ist fast zu kurz, um eine Sache richtig gut zu können. Wann haben wir die 10.000 Stunden? Wann sind wir richtig gut? Naja, wir haben jetzt aktuell 400 Stunden. Wir haben noch nicht mal die Hälfte von einem Zehntel. Moment, Moment. Wir haben noch nicht mal die Hälfte von einem Zehntel. Wir haben noch nicht mal die Hälfte von einem Zehntel, dass wir wirklich gute Podcaster wären. Wir haben nicht mal die Hälfte von einem Zehntel. Ja. Nee, aber die Sache ist ja, wir haben uns ja mehr Stunden damit beschäftigt. Dann legen wir nochmal fünf oben drauf, dann haben wir halt vierhundertfünf Stunden. Das ist immer noch nicht mal die Hälfte von einem Zehntel. Wir sind so weit weg. Wir müssen, gibt's schon einen Podcast mit 10.000 Folgen? Glaube nicht. Aber hast du irgendwas in deinem Leben 10.000 Stunden gemacht? Hast du mir das? Na, gelabert. Na ja, was heißt gelabert? Unterhalten halt. Wie gelabert, was soll das denn heißen? Wie jetzt hier so rumlabert. Nee, das mache ich ausserhalb des Podcasts überhaupt nicht eigentlich.
Setzt du dich nach dem Podcast noch hin und laberst einfach an der Rezeption rum oder was?
Aber ich laber schon gerne mal rum.
Ich laber kaum.
Doch ich laber gern.
Ich gebe ganz präzise Anweisungen und ansonsten treffe ich mich hier mit dir zum Reden.
Manche sagen kühl und unfreundlich.
Ich gebe präzise Anweisungen.
Etwas schneller bitte, etwas schneller bitte, noch etwas schneller bitte.
Perfekt.
Aber es ist diese Lautstärke, diese unnötig krasse Lautstärke.
Mehr Pfeffer bitte, mehr Pfeffer bitte, noch mehr Pfeffer bitte.
Ich will nicht sagen, es ist ziemlich präzise, das will ich nicht sagen.
Es ist halt nur so ein bisschen kühl. Mehr Pommes bitte, mehr Pfeffer bitte. Ich will nicht sagen, es ist ziemlich präzise. Das will ich nicht sagen. Es ist halt nur so ein bisschen klingel.
Mehr Pommes bitte.
Es kommt halt frech rüber.
Perfekt.
Danke, perfekt.
Und dann ist aus.
Und da wird auch nicht gelabert.
Da wird auch nicht gelabert.
Ja, weil neulich sass wir im Kino.
Und der Sound war dir ein bisschen zu leise.
Ja.
Mehr Ton bitte.
Mehr Ton bitte. Es ist bitte! Mehr Ton bitte!
Perfekt!
Und so kriege ich, was ich will,
ohne allzu viel rumzulabern,
sondern präzise,
klare Anweisungen.
Niemand sagt, dass es für mich das Wichtigste ist.
Wir sagen nur alle,
auch Personen aus dem näheren Umfeld,
wir haben uns eigentlich Weniger Kritik bitte! Weniger Kritik bitte! Weniger Kritik bitte! Okay, wir lassen es. Perfekt. Aber labern weiss ich nicht. Du laberst dann oder was? Du triffst dich mit Leuten, um zu labern. Natürlich, weil ich labere. Wieso? Was sagst du? Ich bin so froh, dass wir dich zusammen gefrühstückt haben, sonst hätte ich mir von dir eine Laberei anhören müssen. Nee, beim Frühstücken. Ja, also die Medienszene, das ist ja heute, das ist ja wirklich alles im Wahl. Nein, doch nicht sowas. Also wirklich, das ist ja wirklich, früher hat man ja noch mehr Idealismus. Ey, als jemand, du hast so viel mit mir schon gelabert, hier rumgelabert, das meine ich ja gar nicht. Also habe ich dann angefangen mit, die Medienbubble ist ja allgemein gerade ein bisschen schwierig. Das ist ja nicht, worüber ich labere. Also Twitter ist für mich tot jetzt, also das war wirklich früher mal echt eine tolle Plattform mit viel Potential. Ja, darüber haben wir gesprochen gestern. Aber nur weil das stimmt. Und es ist jetzt leider, ich vermisse das. Und dann hast du gesagt, ja, das siehst du ganz genauso, du wirst gerne eine große Folge machen bei unseren alten Tweets. Ich würde gerne einen grossen Abschied von Twitter nehmen. Finde ich auch schön. Weil ich, für mich, es gibt ein emotionales Bedürfnis, das ist irgendwie so sang- und klanglos untergegangen, irgendwie man wusste gar nicht, was passiert jetzt, geht's weiter wie immer, alles was los und irgendwie steigen immer mehr aus und niemand hat Bock mehr. Und ich finde es schade, weil das ist so. Es ist ein Rotzverein jetzt. Es ist ein Rotzverein, aber ich finde, man sollte das, was gut ist, noch retten in so einem einen Abgesang. Einfach, dass einfach, ob man einfach-Schau. Die große Twitter-Beerdigung,
wo alle noch mal ihre zehn Lieblingstweets
vorlesen dürfen,
wo wir alle noch mal lachen, wo wir alle noch mal sagen,
war eine schöne Zeit und dann aber auch
einfach mal einen Deckel drauf.
Ich kann noch nicht so richtig Abschied nehmen.
Ich muss sagen, damals, als es bei mir losging,
habe ich bei Jan Böhmann dann angefangen,
als Autor zu arbeiten. Wie hieß du da auf Twitter?
Genau, da hieß ich nämlich Spitzenwriter.
Ed Spitzenwriter. Meine Frage ist nur, und genau, die ganzen Autoren, die damals dabei waren, Patrick und Max, die kamen ja alle auch von Twitter. Twitter war damals so eine Bewerbungsplattform. Für die war das, da habe ich erst damit angefangen, weil ich das dann cool fand. Davor habe ich da nichts gemacht, aber ich wusste, dass es die Plattform gibt, hab auch Jan da verfolgt, war das cool, aber hab da nichts geschrieben. Und die haben dann literally ihren Job dadurch bekommen. Und das war halt eine Plattform, die hat wirklich Leben geschapt. Und deswegen finde ich, in Abgesang sollte man schon machen. So eine große ... Mal große Ripp-Twitter und dann noch mal alle,
können ja Leute vielleicht noch mal ... Lass uns doch mal wirklich mal so sagen,
so Max, Patrick, dass die mal vielleicht können,
die mal so eine Sprachnachricht,
einfach mal so deine fünf Lieblingstweets aus der Zeit.
Einfach mal so die besten Tweets.
Ich meine, wir haben legendäre Tweets hier gefeiert.
Mickey is a nickname,
Nicknames are for friends,
and I'm not friends with Michael Maus.
Letztens im Reddit hat jemand gepostet, einen ähnlichen Tweet, der in eine ähnliche Richtung geht, auch sehr schön, der geschrieben hat, Ricky is my nickname, Richard is my Nicholas name. Fantastisch, perfekt, no notes, großartig. Eulogy. Dafür lebt Twitter. Wir machen eine Eulogy, wie so eine Messe. Ich möchte das so religiös verabschieden und zu Grabe tragen. Und dann ist aber auch Schluss. Schluss mit Twitter. Alle löschen ihre Accounts. Aber vielleicht gibt es eine Zukunftsprognose. Oder vielleicht können wir gemeinsam eine andere Plattform vorschlagen. Oder wir ziehen gemeinsam weiter. Genau, wir ziehen gemeinsam weiter. Irgendwie so Blue Sky oder so, Thema oder Filter ist Sigma oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Mit den Tröts, wie hieß es mit dem Manto, Manta? Clubhouse. Mastodon, Mastodon, wo man dann Tröts schreibt und nicht Tweets, weil das ist irgendwie ein Elefant. Ja, aber da habe ich jetzt schon keine Lust mehr drauf.
Ja, klar.
Und bei Blue Sky heisse ich jetzt irgendwie stefantize.social.bluesky.com, wo ich denke, was? Und dann war ich schon raus.
Weil ich will einfach nur add irgendwas und dann sollen da die alten Nasen sein und Hazel Brugger und was auch immer.
Und dann schreibt man da lustige Sachen rein und alle haben sich lieb und machen es for the Gags sake. Ich glaube, Twitter war nie so, auch nicht. Nee, das ist natürlich auch verklärt, man kann natürlich auch die Schattenseiten machen. Ja, genau, wir müssen schon ehrlich, auch einen Abriss. Weil ich glaube, bei uns war es schon einfach eine Fun-Fun-Plattform, weil dann folgt man so einfach den ganzen, weiss ich nicht, Conan-Writers und so. und dann war es einfach so eine lustige Bubble. Das wurde es dann irgendwann eh nicht mehr, vielleicht war es das aber auch wirklich nie. Es gibt, Social-Media-Plattformen sind ja nicht eine Sache, jeder hat ja sein eigenes Umfeld. Oh ja, Experte spricht, danke. Und dann hat es ja auch unterschiedliche Sachen. Ja, ist das alles das Komplexe, als Sie gerade gesagt haben? Ja, ist das alles komplexer als gedacht, aber es war ja wirklich auch so dieser Druck immer. Ich erinnere mich noch, als wir Tweets gepostet hatten und dann irgendwie hundert Sterne in einer Stunde, ansonsten werden sie gelöscht. So einfach dieser knallharte, evolutionäre Druck, einfach zu sagen, alles wird rausgeschmissen, was nicht sofort funktioniert, ist natürlich auch hart, aber hat natürlich auch so Höchstleistungen angetrieben. Ja, vor allem auch nie in Betracht gezogen, dass es irgendwie 14 Uhr ist, alle gerade arbeiten, außer wir Dusselköppel. Ich glaube, man hatte so eine halbe Stunde immer, dann ist der Tweet wieder verschwunden aus den Feeds. Ja, das viel Gold auch dann verschütt gegangen. Ich will nur sagen, Fragen, kann jemand, weil ich habe schon alles gelöscht, ein bisschen vorschnell. Du hast alle Tweets gelöscht. Alle Entwürfe, alle Tweets. Ich habe mein Account gelöscht. Warum denn, Stefan? Mein Account gelöscht einfach. Sind die dann noch irgendwo da? Ich weiß es nicht. Wenn du mich jetzt da findest, habe ich nur meinen Zugang gelöscht, da ist der Account weg. Keine Ahnung, das werden wir alles recherchieren. Es gibt auch Archive.org mit diesen riesen Serverfarben auf der Rückseite des Mondes. Ja, guck mal nach. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, was die alles archivieren. Speichern die nicht alte Twitter-Accounts. Ich habe gehört, das ist jetzt schwer geworden, da Sachen auszulesen oder so, aber das kann auch nur seit der X-Zeit sein, ich weiß es wirklich nicht. Das ist mein technischer Sachverstand. Wir müssen bei Twitter einbrechen, wir müssen bei X aufs Dach klettern, rein mit einer Bohrmaschine, uns durch die Decke bohren, um von oben auf die Server zu gehen. Das klingt eins zu eins wie so ein Larger-than-life-Mission-impossible-Plot. Wir müssen bei der Firma X einbrechen. Weil wir irgendwie so einen peinlichen Liebesbrief, Liebestweet gesendet haben und den müssen wir löschen. Und dann müssen wir rein, bevor sie ihn liest und so weiter. Und der böse Chef Elon Musk. Also alles klingt wirklich wie ausgedacht. Du, ich meine, ein anderes Thema sind natürlich so Twitter-Liebeleien, Twitter-Flirts und so, da gibt es natürlich auch ganz viel, was natürlich auch dann immer so eine merkwürdige Kommunikation ist, wenn man zwei Menschen, die aber über so eine Drittplattform kommunizieren und dann immer, ah, sie hat den Tweet geliked, ich like ihren Tweet, hin und her, boah, rückblickend war das so unfassbar ätzend und auch toxisch auf eine Art, immer so dieses Überbande und man weiss immer nie genau, was bedeutet das und so. Ach, das war schrecklich. Aber war natürlich spaßig und flirtig zu der Zeit, was so ein bisschen vielleicht meine verspältete Teenie-Phase war, aber rückblickend sehr anstrengend. Ja, da war ich nicht so drin, ich habe nur von außen mitbekommen, wie viel Druck das für manche war. Es war für mich nie eine Flirty-Plattform. Weil meine Teenie-Phase danach kam. Wir waren beide spät dran. Und das sind diese vier Jahre, die uns trennen vielleicht, aber genau, das machen wir mal, finde ich gut, wenn wir da mal so Strich drunter machen. Finde ich auch gut, das einmal wirklich zu beenden, vielleicht zum Ende des Jahres oder Anfang nächsten Jahres, dass wir frisch rein starten. Wir gucken mal, dass wir mal schauen, dass wir mal schauen, wie wir das machen. Richtig. Wir schauen mal, ob wir gucken und wir gucken mal, ob wir am Ende mal schauen. Wir gucken mal, dass wir mal schauen, dass wir das mal an den Start bekommen. Ob wir am Ende schauen oder nicht, müssen wir dann gucken. Das Ende eines jeden Zoom-Calls.
Ja, schauen wir mal, dass wir das mal machen, dass wir das mal gucken.
Genau. Ich kann das nicht mehr. Ich war noch nicht wieder im Zoom-Call und ich dachte, das war jetzt der letzte. Ich mache noch einmal Zoom, noch einmal Teams, noch einmal Skype. Ich finde, es sollte ein Zoom-Feature geben, wollte ich letztens pitchen an Dr. Zoom. Und zwar, nachdem Zoom beendet ist oder irgendein Call, kriegt jeder Teilnehmer ein Pop-up mit War dieser Call Zeitverschwendung? Und jeder drückt Ja und Nein und es wird anonymisiert, es wird anonymisiert und am Ende kriegt der, der das Meeting erstellt hat, eine automatisierte Zusammenfassung, vier von fünf Teilnehmern empfanden dieses Meeting als Zeitverschwendung. So, und ich will es noch konkreter. Ich möchte, dass, wenn man quasi einen Call verlässt, der, also angenommen hat er einen Call mit so vier Leuten. Ja. Und dann verlässt jemand den, weil er weg muss oder sie, verlässt den Call, dann wird aus der Kachel, wo noch das Gesicht zu sehen war, eine Umfrage, wie derjenige diejenige performt hat. Oh, hei. Also, war die Person Zeitverschwendung in dem Call? Da kannst du so Smileys von so rot bis grün geben und so Tipps und so, was dir gut gefallen hat und was nicht. Ich habe die Vorstellung, dass jemand rausgeht und dann wird diese Kachel zu einer Umfrage und alle, erst mal still und alle tippen dann direkt. Ja, tippen ewig langes Feedback einfach. Wenn der Call vorbei ist, kannst du jeden bewerten. Ja, weil das Problem ist oft, denke ich mir, Call, absolute Zeitverschwendung, vor allem diese Terminieren ist immer so nervig. Du hast dann Call um elf und denkst dir, es ist jetzt acht, ich kann nichts mehr machen. Warum muss man sich sehen? So super nervig. Neuerdings muss man sich immer sehen. Warum muss man sich sehen? Wollt ihr, zurück zum Telegramm, biep, biep, biep, biep, reicht so. Ja, nicht mal hören. Und dann, es gibt immer keinen richtigen Adressaten für gescheiterte Meetings. So, an wen schreibe ich jetzt? Wer ist dafür verantwortlich? Weil nicht jeder, der den Call aufsetzt, ist auch sozusagen der Chef des Calls. Das macht dann oft auch jemand anders oder so. Aber einfach, dass man dann mal zurück eine Mail an alle, die teilgenommen haben, waren. 95 Prozent der Teilnehmer empfanden dieses Meeting als Zeitverschwendung. Ja, als reinste Zeitverschwendung. Ich glaube, als reinste Zeitverschwendung,
Zeit, die wir nie wieder
zurückbekommen werden.
Man kann nur klicken auf
war okay und
dieser Call war die reinste Zeitverschwendung,
die man uns im Leben nicht zurückgeben kann.
Ja, wir hätten so viele
andere schöne Dinge während dieser Zeit
tun können, nichts wäre besser
gewesen. Also das kann man
dann zusammenfassen und dann haben, glaube ich,
innerhalb von ein paar Wochen
Ansonsten Andere schöne Dinge wären dieser Zeit tun können, nichts wäre besser gewesen. Also das kann man dann zusammenfassen und dann haben, glaube ich, innerhalb von ein paar Wochen alle irgendwie das Verständnis, hey, das ist wirklich alles Zeitverschwendung, lass uns das alles lassen. Das war meine Idee an Doktor Zoom, ich habe leider ihn nicht erreichen können, meine Telefonate wurden leider alle abgewimmelt, falls ihr zuhört, bitte dieses Feature integrieren. So. Weil es ihr ... Telefonate sind auch scheisse. Ich war neulich für so eine neue Steuersoftware-Shit,
also wirklich so trockenste trockenes
Thema-Kacke. Da ging dann
was nicht bei der Anmeldung und da war dann
eine falsche E-Mail-Adresse hinterlegt, da musste ich bei dieser Service-Hotline
anrufen und dann hat mir der Typ
ganz, ganz
langsam erklärt, dass ich falsch bin bei ihm
und dass ich gerade, dass ich diese
Nummer nie wieder anrufen sollte,
weil ich gerade anderen Menschen, die diese Hotline brauchen, als wäre er der fucking Notruf, als wäre er 1-1-0. Aber er war in seiner Welt die 1-1-0 für die Probleme dieser Steuersoftware. Man hat mir aber super langsam und dann ungelogen wirklich zehn Minuten erklärt, wo ich demnächst anrufen soll und war so richtig so klein, klein, klein genau. Das war so, ich musste so lachen, weil er so langsam erklärt hat, was ich jetzt machen soll. Und ganz ehrlich, schauen Sie sich vielleicht auch mal, wenn Sie sich diese Software jetzt zu Gemüte führen, auch mal die YouTube-Videos an. Und dann geben Sie aber bitte auch dringend unseren Namen da ein, weil da gibt es ein paar Drittanbieter, die haben auch YouTube-Videos und ich wurde so nervös. Aber das ist genial, weil vielleicht ist das einfach eine Zeitschiene-Taktik. Das Schlimmste im Callcenter, ich habe auch im Callcenter gearbeitet, ich kann mich da so ein bisschen reinfassen, das sind die Kollegen. Deswegen spreche ich es an. Das Schlimmste, wenn du angerufen wirst, ist, du weißt nicht, kann ich das Problem lösen oder nicht. Wenn du das Problem lösen kannst, easy, das ist der einfachste Anruf der Welt, du weißt genau, was das Problem ist, du kannst genau Schritt für Schritt durchgehen, du hast das Problem schon tausend mal gelöst.
Aber wie oft ist das der Fall prozentual?
Das ist 90 Prozent der Fall. Und dann gibt es aber Anrufe, wo du merkst, oh fuck, das kann ich nicht lösen. Und das sind die stressigen Anrufe, weil du weisst nicht, kann ich dem jetzt irgendwas geben oder nicht oder irgendwas, weil die allermeisten Probleme sind, eine das gleiche Problem. Bei uns beim Coin Center war es immer, die Leute sagen eine Nummer, anstatt die Nummer einzutippen, weil das war ja so ein Abzockding mit irgendwie Kontaktanzeigen und dann hast du halt so eine Kontaktnummer und dann musst du die eintippen und dann kannst du der Person auf dem Anrufbeinwanderer sprechen. Okay, wir spiel mal durch, ich rufe an bei dir beim Coin Center. So, ähm, bieb, bieb, bieb, interactive, will guten Tag. Hi, ist die New York Times, ähm, ich wollte kurz fragen. Nein, no, no, no, Blacklist, no, aufgelegt, okay, guter Fall, weil ich wusste, dass die New York Times gibt, Blacklist, die mussten wir immer abwimmeln, ja. Okay, ja, Hallo, und zwar wollte ich nur fragen, warum das nicht bei mir funktioniert. Also irgendwie diese Nummern, das funktioniert nicht. Ich sage die dann und dann passiert nichts. So, und jetzt weiß ich, die Welt ist gut. Und jetzt redest du jetzt langsamer oder? Jetzt rede ich langsamer, weil jetzt weiß ich alles easy. Weil in der Zeit, in der ich rede, kann ich keinen weiteren Anruf kriegen. Das heißt, alle Anrufe gehen an die Kollegen. Prämisse ist eigentlich bei allen Jobs, die man von außen betrachtet, immer Faulheit. Ja, klar. Ja, und zwar, Sie müssen die Nummer eintippen auf Ihrem Telefon. So, Problem, jetzt schon verraten, was ich machen muss. Ja, das ist ein Problem. Und eigentlich will ich jetzt auflegen. Können Sie vielleicht noch mal erklären, was genau Sie gemacht haben? Ja genau, also ich habe angerufen und dann sollte ich die Nummer übermitteln und dann habe ich die Nummer gesagt. Also bei mir war es jetzt die 1, 4, 7, 7, 3. Können Sie noch mal durchgeben die Nummer bitte? Schinden, schinden, schinden und dann am Ende sagst du ihm, okay,, sie müssen das eintippen mit ihren Fettfingern so, zack, fertig. Aber das ist immer das Ding, weil als Callcenter, ich bin ja so ein bisschen soziophob auch, wenn das Telefon klingelt, war immer mega Stress. Und dann ist immer so, wenn du weißt, ah, okay, easy. Wenn das das Problem ist, dann weißt du, alles ist gut. Aber wenn es heißt so, ich habe jetzt hier eine Nachricht draufgesprochen und dann kam irgendwie, konnte nicht gespeichert werden, ich denke mir, what, nie gehört in meinem Leben diese Nachricht, diese Fehlermeldung, äh, äh, ja, da müssen sie, ach so, können ich denn, ja, aber die haben mir jetzt schon zwei Euro abgebucht, ach so, da muss ich nochmal gucken, im, im, also, ah, oh, ich sehe gerade, jetzt, ähm, geht's, geht's, ja, ich sehe, ah, ich sehe gerade, jetzt geht's, ich, ich sehe gerade, jetzt geht's.
Ich habe Sie angerufen.
Sie wollten mir doch gerade.
Perfekt, wunderbar.
Da wurden wir zusammengeschleust.
Dann passt's.
Ich hätte auch eine Frage.
Ich wollte auch das Callcenter anrufen.
Ach so, ich wollte auch anrufen.
Ja, genau.
Ja, das ist immer die Notlösung.
Wenn gar nichts funktioniert, tu so, als seist du ein Anrufer, der durch ein Kabelknoten tatsächlich zusammengekommen ist. Habe ich aber auch mal gemacht. Das hat Spaß gemacht, die zu verbinden miteinander. Irgendwann hatte ich dieses Telefon so gemeistert, dass ich wusste, wie man die miteinander verbindet. Das ist krass, was möglich ist mit Telefonen. Richtig krass. Falls ihr euch jetzt fragt, warum kommt nach dieser Folge ein Pop-up, war diese Folge Zeitverschwendung ja oder nein, ist ein neues Feature, das wir einführen. Falls ihr die Folge beendet, könnt ihr abstimmen und dann wissen wir vielleicht. Und wenn wir eins lieben, dann Feedback. Wir lieben Feedback. Bitte weniger Feedback. Bitte weniger Feedback. Bitte weniger Feedback. Perfekt. Macht's gut, haut rein. Macht's gut, schöne Woche, schöne Vorweihnachtszeit.
Lies, bis bald euch dummer Steine rein.
Macht's gut, haut rein, legt euch selbst keine Steine in den Weg, bitte.
Tschüss, macht's gut, wir heben ab, bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss.
Ciao.